-It is an honor to introduce
my first guest.
He's the 44th President
of the United States
and the author
of this best-selling
new book called
"A Promised Land."
Here is President Barack Obama.
Hi, President --
-Jimmy.
-Thank you so much for
coming back to the show.
You look great.
And I know we don't really
have a way of really
keeping in touch.
But, gosh,
I really missed you, bud.
-I missed you.
Although, I kind of like
the whole disheveled --
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, sweater.
-No. No, no.
-Slightly --
-I can't --
-Little bit of stubble look.
-No.
-Now, you're back
behind a desk, tie.
-[ Laughs ]
-I can't -- for you --
-You know, hair product.
-Yeah. I mean, I'm swearing swim
shorts, swim trunks, under here,
but I'm not going
to show you that.
But, yeah, I got to dress
up for you.
I always think of the time
when I came to the White House
for the Fourth of July
and I opened up
for the Foo Fighters
for a veterans...
-Yeah.
-...party that you had,
and I got -- I was so nervous.
I got really dressed up
there as well.
And I was wearing -- I think I
was wearing a three-piece suit,
and it was probably 98 degrees.
-It was really hot.
-It was ridiculous --
And Michelle was like,
"Oh, you poor thing.
Loosen your tie or something."
I mean, there was sweat
coming through my collar,
and you were like,
"Didn't you get the memo?
It's a barbecue."
And I go --
-Come on.
-I was awful.
I was sweating so much.
But, yeah.
Those were so many --
so many fun memories
hanging out with you, and --
Congrats on the book.
Here it is.
Great cover, by the way.
Great look.
-Thank you.
-Just crisp, clean.
It's a -- it's not a quick read.
But, it is a --
you get your money's worth.
Look at this.
I mean, that's a big book.
-You know what?
I think you can
handle it, Jimmy.
I really do.
-Well, I mean, I got up
to the part with the pictures.
And that's where I got
really excited.
[ Laughter ]
I -- before we get into
everything, how is the family?
How is Michelle?
How are the girls?
-You know, Michelle is great.
She sends her love.
-Aww.
-The girls have been with us
throughout the,
you know, pandemic.
Yeah, they've been doing
remote college.
Malia's a senior at Harvard.
And Sasha's a sophomore
at Michigan.
-Wow. That's great.
-So...
you know, as we've talked
about parenting,
now I'm a little bit ahead
of you in age.
-How is it?
-You go through this cycle.
They love you.
They think you're terrific.
You get to around 12.
-[ Laughs ]
-They think you're a loser.
-Yeah.
I got my first eye roll, yeah.
-But by the time they come
back to you and, in this case,
you know,
Sasha's now 19, Malia's 22.
You know, they, suddenly,
like you again.
-[ Laughs ]
-And they're interesting
and they're smart,
and they're funnier
than you are.
-Yeah.
-So it's been a joy
to have them around.
You know, I think they have,
obviously,
started getting cabin fever
hanging out with us
as much as they are.
But I don't mind it.
-I got my first eye roll
the other day,
which was pretty interesting.
-Oh, man.
How'd do you handle it?
-I couldn't -- I really --
It really broke my heart.
I go,
"You're my number one fan.
You can't --
you laugh at everything.
Every joke I tell,
you laugh at.
I -- I -- And she was like...
-Oh, man.
-Yeah.
-Wait till they're 14. Whoo!
-I cant -- I can't even.
I can't even.
Are you -- in this
past four years,
I think the last time
I talked to you,
we were talking about what you
were most excited about doing,
and I think you were like,
just even pressing
a button on an elevator,
or, it was like the simplest
little things
that you did not do.
Have you done that?
Have you taken out the trash?
Have you --
-I -- yeah, look,
I mean, there's a bunch of
honey do list items
that I have been carrying out.
Don't seem quite as romantic
as they did at the time.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, I've driven
a couple of times,
although in very restricted
areas.
-Stick shift or automatic?
-And much to the --
Uh, automatic.
-Me too.
-You know, I didn't want
to cause, you know, havoc.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-But, you know, the thing
that I haven't been able to do
that I thought I was
going to be able to do --
and Michelle knew I was
an idiot to think this way,
was, I thought I could,
like, go around
and take a walk sometimes.
And it turns out that...
-Yeah, you're you.
-...I can't do that.
I cannot -- I can't do that.
So -- Although we've been
doing some bike rides.
'Cause you're moving fast enough
that even if they...
-They go, "Hey, is that --"
-...spot you,
it's too late.
-Yeah, exactly.
-You're gone by that time.
-Probably it's even bet--
if you --
You can't even do it alone,
I'm just saying,
but if it's you and Michelle
and the kids,
everyone's like,
"Wha-- wha-- what, what?
That's like --"
People would just freak out.
-Well, the thing about
Michelle when we go
bike riding together,
she's this -- she thinks
she's in a race, right?
I mean, it --
on the Alps or something.
And she's just powering
through,
and she's about a mile
ahead of me, and...
-Oh, no.
-I'm sort of meandering,
trying to figure out
how to shift gears, and so --
-Yeah, I'm cruising, yeah.
Me too.
-Yeah, it's not that romantic.
-It's more of a workout.
-For this, you took a deep dive
into your journey
to the White House,
and your first few years
as president.
You also released
an audiobook version,
which you narrate,
which I think is great.
But I was going to ask you,
when it came time to record it,
was there any part of you
that was kicking yourself
for writing such a long book?
[ Laughter ]
-Absolutely.
You know, you don't --
You don't realize
how exhausting it is
to just sit there and read.
And it gives you
a newfound respect for,
you know, professional actors
and narrators and so forth,
because after about three hours
I was whooped.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And, you know, you look,
"Really? We only got through
ten pages?
What do you mean?"
-You're like, "Hey,
can we get Tom Cruise
to do this or something?"
-Exactly.
But, you know,
the goal of my --
my book was to
tell a story
about, yes, policy,
and you know,
the Affordable Care Act
and how we got Bin Laden
and all that stuff.
But also to try to pull
the curtain back
and give people a sense
of what it's like for a family
to go on this weird journey.
And -- and, you know,
how Michelle and the girls
and I
had to try to hang on to
our sense of who we were
and normalcy,
and with highs and lows
and tensions and stresses.
-Yeah.
-And kind of come out
of the other end intact.
And so part of my goal here
was not just to give
some dry report,
but, you know,
to describe for people
what it's like,
you know, the first night
you sleep in the White House
and you kind of realize,
"What the heck?
How'd I end up here?" Or...
-Yeah. Do you remember
the first thing you saw
when you actually walked
into the White House?
-Were you like -- Did you
look at like a phone
or an old painting or something
and you're like,
"Wait, I'm actually --
I'm the White House"?
-All of the above.
-Yeah.
-And, you know,
the interesting thing is,
is that you don't --
you literally are moved in
while you're being sworn in.
So you haven't --
The Bushes were very gracious.
They had given us a tour,
but, you know,
you're not really
paying attention.
It kind of feels like
you're in a museum.
Uh...
You get inaugurated.
There are a bunch of balls.
You're shaking hands
and schmoozing
and watching parades.
And then you go home,
quote/unquote,
and suddenly
you're in this place where
the Gettysburg Address
is next to --
in the next room, and...
you know, you realize
that your life
is not going to be the same,
and trying to make sure that
you're maintaining perspective.
You know, I discuss a lot
in the book...
you know, one of the greatest
accomplishments, I think,
of my presidency
for both Michelle and me
was raising two girls
in this very strange environment
and them turning out to be
these wonderful,
not at all entitled,
you know,
kind, thoughtful people.
-Yeah.
-Partly because
of my mother-in-law,
who, you know, she --
we were very lucky to have her
come stay with us.
And, you know,
she'd look at the girls
if they were acting up
and she'd say,
"What are you guys doing?"
-Yeah.
-"You know you didn't
do anything."
-Good.
-"You're just here
for the ride."
-You need that, yeah.
-"Settle down."
-Yeah, and just grounding them.
So...
And part of the reason
I wanted to personalize it was
so that young people
who read it,
who are interested
in public service,
who are interested in government
or just changing the world,
they can kind of see, "Okay,
here's somebody
who is kind of normal
and was able to do
some important stuff.
And maybe, I can, too."
-Yeah.
-And hopefully inspires them
to get involved.
-Yeah.
You wrote that,
yeah, you want this --
this book is for, like,
young people, in their 20s,
and who want
to change the world.
I was going to ask you, are you
inspired by your own daughters?
-I am.
You know, they and their
friends, you know,
during this summer after
the tragedy of George Floyd
and the protests and activism,
you know, they found ways
to get involved
that were very smart
and thoughtful and practical.
And they got
their friends involved.
This whole generation of young
people coming up
are smart,
thoughtful, sophisticated.
And they really believe
all the platitudes
about everybody's equal
and we should treat
everybody fairly.
And, you know,
we don't like racism
and we don't like discriminating
against people
because of their
sexual orientation.
It's second nature to them.
And there is a courage and
conviction that they bring to it
that really is inspiring
and makes me optimistic.
You know, it's a matter of us
old heads getting out of the way
and making sure
we don't break things so badly
that by the time
they're in charge,
you know, it's not too late.
-Yeah.
There's also some good stories
in here about you choosing
Joe Biden as your
vice president,
and you do a great job in there
describing his character.
I've met him a couple times.
He's just very memorable,
very charming.
What is your favorite memory
of working
or spending time with Joe Biden?
-You know, the thing about Joe
is he genuinely loves people.
Everybody.
-Yeah.
-It's not a put-on.
You know, there's some folks,
and I'm sure you've seen them
in the entertainment industry,
do not name names, where they're
all fun and laughs,
you know, in public and then...
-Cameras off.
-[ Laughs ] Cameras off
and they're curmudgeons.
-Oh, yeah.
-Right?
-Joe is exactly
who he appears to be.
And, you know, probably
my strongest memories of Joe
are when we were
campaigning together.
You know, I'd work the rope
lines after I'd made a speech,
you know, and I'd hug babies.
-Yeah.
-You know, kiss grandmas.
And we'd go around and
shake hands and all this stuff.
And I felt like
I'd shaken every hand
and I'm finished
with the rope line.
And I look back and, like,
Joe's just starting.
I mean, I think he's gotten
the life story
of the first four people.
-Yeah.
-And so, campaigning with Joe
meant you were going to be late.
But because he really cares
about, you know, hearing people
and letting them know
that they're important.
And I think that fundamental
character of his
is exactly what we need
right now
after so much division
and anger and frustration.
Just having somebody
who likes people,
cares about 'em,
knows their struggles.
I think that's going to make
a big difference,
and I think Kamala will bring
some of those same values
to bear when they get sworn in.
-Even seeing him with,
unfortunately, with his boot,
the -- he fractured
his foot or whatever,
it just makes you --
I'm actually going like,
man, this is exactly --
Already, I'm more interested
in that --
If that's a scandal,
I will take that.
I just think, that's normal,
that's human,
that's, you know...
-That's what happens
with normal people.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Playing with their dog,
so...
-Was it tough for the past
four years,
was it difficult to sit back
and not say anything?
And go like, "I have to respect
the presidency, I understand."
But -- 'cause I know,
I'm speaking
for a lot of people,
where I'm just like, let's --
let's call Obama right now
and get him to go, "Hey, enough.
Hey, yo.
Stop it.
You stop it."
And just yell at him.
-I -- Look, yeah.
It was difficult as a citizen.
I mean, people have asked me,
they asked me,
even before I left office,
"Are you going to miss
the presidency?"
I like the fact that, you know,
you have eight years
if you're lucky.
And then it's somebody else's
turn and you pass the baton.
And you become a citizen again.
And because I think
that constantly refreshes
our democracy.
So, I wasn't one of these people
who had to be dragged off
the stage, in that sense.
-Yep.
-But there's no doubt that,
let's talk about the pandemic,
for example, right now.
We had written up
a pandemic playbook.
We had -- I had experienced
a pandemic,
as I write about in the book,
with H1N1,
six months into my presidency
we were dealing with a pandemic.
Then, we had Ebola.
We had set up a whole structure.
We had had a task force
in the White House.
We had, you know,
deployed scientists
as an early-warning system
in countries around the world
to ensure their cooperation
so that we get ahead of the game
if something like this happened.
And so, when you see all that
discarded and ignored,
just at the time
when you need it most,
and knowing the consequences
for, you know,
families across the country,
yes, that was frustrating.
And you know, people I think
were surprised
by my bluntness maybe,
during the campaign season.
And they said, "Oh, he must've
had all this stuff bottled up."
It wasn't so much that there was
a bunch of personal outrage
bottled up,
as it was a genuine sense
that, you know,
good government matters.
And some of the norms
and, you know,
practices we use
to just make sure
that our democracy
is civil and functions,
the kind of transition
that I write about
that George Bush
and Laura Bush extended to us,
and that we extended
to the Trumps,
those kinds of things
are important.
You know, sometimes, we think
of politics as so different
from daily life, but it's not.
You know, we don't have
rules about
just being courteous
or being thoughtful
or trying to hear
another person's point of view.
We can't police that
all the time.
It matters how we express
our values
and interact
with each other every day.
That's what
we teach our kids.
-Yeah.
-And that matters
in the White House
and in Congress as well.
It's obviously been
a tough time for our country,
but you are an optimist,
as am I.
And you're
the "Yes, we can" guy,
you're the "Audacity of Hope"
guy.
What keeps you feeling
optimistic?
-I talked about it.
The young people that I meet.
And, you know, Michelle and I
are focusing on
building up our foundation,
and our entire mission
is actually
to train the next generation
of leaders.
And, you know,
the Presidential Center
we're building in Chicago
will be focused on
creating training centers
and classrooms
and convenings of these
amazing young people
that you meet
all around the country
who are working on
climate change
and criminal justice reform
and, you know,
educating kids.
And when you talk to
these young people,
not just in America
but around the world.
It makes you optimistic.
It gives you a sense that
they're as idealistic
but maybe a little more
sophisticated
and practical than any
previous generation.
-There's so much more I want
to talk to you about.
More with President Barack Obama
when we return, everybody.